alors si la reine Anne d'Autriche
s'occupe à ce point de l'éducation
sexuelle de son fils c'est parce qu'elle
garde en mémoire la cuisante expérience
de sa propre nuit de noces avec Louis
XIII son mari
[Musique]
longtemps été
négligé par son mari et elle tenait à
s'assurer effectivement que que Louis
XIV soit initié correctement aux choses
de l'amour
je me souviens de ma nuit de noce avec
feu mon épouse Louis XIII nous ne
connaissions rien aux choses de l'amour
se fut d'épouvantable
on dit allez savoir qu'entre la première
nuit de la deuxième nuit 9 mois se sont
écoulés c'est quand même quelque chose
de terrible
[Musique]
lorsque Madame de Beauvais a terminé ce
qu'elle devait faire avec le jeune Louis
la reine chose incroyable va devant
toute la cour annoncer la bonne nouvelle
notre roi fut glorieux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui quand une maman est très
proche de son enfant peut-être trop
proche de son gamin on aura tendance à
dire qu'elle se comporte et ce n'est pas
du tout une agent bien sûr comme une mer
juive vous savez la même en juive qui
s'occupe du gamin du début jusqu'à la
fin même marié elle continue de
s'immiscer au sein du couple et bien
Anne d'Autriche c'est cela elle va
s'occuper très tôt de tout ce qui
concerne son fils l'alimentation le
protocole le pouvoir et la sexualité
elle veut tout contrôler y compris la
première qui fera de louer un homme
Anne d'Autriche est une femme comblée
son fils est maintenant capable
d'assurer de façon certaine la
continuité de la dynastie
en bonne pédagogue madame de Beauvais a
donc réussi sa mission d'ailleurs pour
cela elle va être grassement récompensée
elle va être curieusement payée
d'ailleurs puisque on ne va pas lui
donner quelques dizaines de milliers de
livres pour avoir
des niaiser le petit Louis on va la
payer j'allais dire en brique n'ont pas
en brique mais en pierre parce qu'on
avait un stock de pierre au Louvre qui
n'avait pas été utilisé et bien on lui
offre cette énorme stock de pierre pour
qu'elle puisse se construire son hôtel
de Beauvais à Paris
grâce à Madame de Beauvais Louis XIV est
devenu ce que l'on peut appeler un homme
à femme doté d'un appétit sexuel
insatiable
ainsi le jeune roi passe son adolescence
dans l'insouciance la plus totale
[Musique]
acceptez-vous le roi
avec joie oui oui alors avancer
[Musique]
je crois que Louis XIV a besoin qu'on le
regarde avec intérêt avec gourmandise
avec envie Louis XIV a besoin d'être
désiré le roi des abeilles avec tout un
essaim de jolies femmes autour de lui
qui ne rêvait qu'une seule chose c'est
conquérir le cœur du roi il est assez
misogyne mais en même temps c'est un
passionné des femmes un grand amoureux
il faut se souvenir aussi qu'au 17e
siècle les distractions sont rares il y
a la guerre et vous parlez d'une
distraction il y a la chasse il y a il y
a le sexe donc il y a quand même pas
quantité de choses à faire le soir au
coin du feu
[Musique]